i know in the meantime when you try to
find the record i'm trying to share with
you any music
of really dope people that put out music
though all right rory down to zz top
like zz top got a new one coming
on the way he's just scrolling he just
scrolled through that like yo zz top got
something nah i
wrote down a bunch of good music that
came out easy top i got something i'll
talk
my girl
[Laughter]
are you doing everything i am
are you gonna play the whole retirement
song are you how do you how do you feel
huh are you gonna play the whole
retirement song
the whole retirement song yeah i got you
parks yeah yeah come on
relax baby what's the whole rap why do
why do rappers
still do this
yeah i got you parks no don't do that
y'all
don't do that nah we gotta do that
basically stop being a hussy looking
rory rory whole vlog rory
rory please turn this off mike
he didn't retire so rory's on something
but listen
listen listen listen logic
logic
i don't want to fall asleep here logic
you don't get to announce this why not
every other rapper's done it what the
[ __ ] is he talking about
why because we don't care somebody cares
no they don't yes they do he sells man
right now there's a million likes on
this picture somebody cares no they're
happy that he's leaving why do you think
why you think i got the [ __ ]
celebration song cued up man
oh my god
that's why he leaving hey let's
celebrate logic getting the [ __ ] out of
here now you guys get some empathy for
me
go half black man go half black man
half black man half black man half black
man you strong ass bricks
what's the matter what is going on in
2020 man
logic give my guy some [ __ ] logic logic
he's sold a [ __ ] ton of records he has a
lot of fans he sells out mad [ __ ]
you should have retired a long time ago
logically who cares what do you mean
but we don't have to listen to him you
never needed to
he has mad fans don't do that [ __ ] and i
don't even like his music but don't do
that [ __ ]
he can rap that's what i love about him
oh please you love his music
you love his music rory i bought the
deluxe logic says
i'm officially announcing my retirement
with the release of
no pressure executive produced by no id
july 24th
no idea that's when you know it's time
to retire when the no id
shout don't make me look forward to it i
think no idea exactly produces all this
i don't i was gonna say
yeah go away go away shut up
stop shooting and bail and i'm trying to
tell jokes go away we're not shooting
them
we just want to know why you don't want
to hear from logic anymore you know what
i'm saying
no that's enough i like life you can rap
you can rap
very well nicest guy in the world too
so everything you're saying don't faze
him
see look i like the some symbolism of
his album cover if this is indeed the
he does have really good elements logic
float away from the speakers
i think it's the other way around joe i
think the speakers are floating away i
wouldn't doubt it
my girl my girl hey the speakers look
like
they would be floating away from this
trash
that's [ __ ] up no it's nice
hey if he wasn't retiring i wasn't
listening to this you retired him
what are you gonna try and soften it up
talking about i'm gonna go be a dad
no no no no we support that [ __ ] yeah
be a father
always like lg said but yeah the speaker
should be floating away
the little console with the amplifier
whatever that is
float away from him look at logic with
his [ __ ] shirt up get out of here
he is and has been horrible for a long
time
horrible in joe's opinion okay that's
fair no as a rapper he could be the
greatest guy in the world like vin
staples tells me
everybody that met him tells me that
he's a very nice guy this is not a
personal attacker who he
shout out for my little cousin oh come
on you can't yeah i can't [ __ ] on this
guy
you [ __ ] the nicest guy come on joe
come on joe
[Music]
joey
you don't see the correlation i don't
like deflection from rory i don't like
rory i've said this on this podcast i
don't like rory playing
anytime logic comes up you interrupted
me my god
i'll stop i don't like rory playing a
really hard song that i enjoy instead of
telling me about the time he asked logic
to wish his niece a happy birthday
i want to hear that okay my niece well
not my niece my little cousin
was a really really really big logic fan
how does he feel about joe
and you hit logic of your lodge i did
not hit lodge
first of all i don't know we can't call
him
what do you think rory said uh
hey logic logical he's sure he loves you
a lot
longer hey hey logical
hey logie roar here
you cut your shorts your boy roy here
just want to let you know the album is
flames
[Music]
hey huge fans love what you're doing
can't wait for the new music huge fan
yeah get logic the [ __ ] out of here
hopefully i never have to hear from him
again
all the greats come back all of them all
the greats
that's funny parks all the greats come
back and logic uh
and check this out i'm listening to this
album
take that you ain't gonna try and get
your retirement bars off
if it's dope you're gonna say it's dope
100 all right cool 100
all right cool i respect that
retiring from the game smoking diet
strain like when he do all of that
like if he get in there i had to leave
it like all right
you taking us there okay but if he about
to chance me to death and tell me yo i'm
going if i'm
leaving to fatherhood no i'm cool on
that yeah
you gotta get your [ __ ] off can you
probably gotta start telling me the
stats you know what the dad box can
y'all promise me that we can do a logic
review next week please
of course is that what it drops please
or whatever it drops
i don't know i didn't look at the date
for this july 24th
july 24th july 24th fade to orange
we are ready for it i will give you a
detailed face orange says fade to black
emotional
oh [ __ ] pansy feed the orange they
call the pansy
well you were at the fades of blackboard
yes
no logic i hope the album is good man
because if it's not we're going to kill
you parker want to mix this out so bad
shut up
no cool all right
i cannot listen to these lies turn this
off turn this off
i cannot listen to these lies 444 says
that was a lie [ __ ]
this was well before then at that point